T ND IN NES G O STRAIGHT TOB IN
IVE A SPEECH
ABOUT 30 MINUTES
HE, OF C NOT
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN FLORIDA.
I  W SHOW YOU W
YOU ONE COURTRM IMAGE OF THE
HE WAS
IN THE
HONEST, MAYBELL DOESN'T REALLYE
BUOSSING HIS WITH ME, OFRSE,
FORMER TRUHI
TY,  THING.
OUR REPORTERS WHO  THE ISLAS
TT WAN SILENT.DESCRIBE HOVER, SF
ADT AT
ALL.
HIS LAWYER DIDLLHIM.
ENTED HIAST.
DO YOU YOU READ NG INT
>> SOME. AHIM AL.ESENTED THE WHH
TRESNEOPLS THERE.
SO HE'TRYING TO
DYNA SIMPLG D THE OWR.OLUTELY.
SIAT YOU THAT.DID YOE'HITHE TIM
LN AMERICAN THAT SEE A DAY KEK
THE FWRAFBTY O
OVERSTATED.VED
WA NT  NOW HERE WE ARE TALKING
WHW LAG TO GET A
BE BY HIS SIDE IN BEDMERONSPIRAM
AT TTAAN
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.ION BETWEW
HAVE REPRESENTATION YET,
DON WHA
WO-  HE WOULD EVER
TUUMSOHAT WE KNOW IN
THE , HO AT THEM.
ONE, DO K SOMEBODY MAYNVINCE TH,
NOTWITHSTAG, P
OF HIS SER TO THIDT  P HE IS
OFISILG THE COUNTRY BYERVING
THE PRESIDENT.
THATMA HARD FOR
HITOP.UNLESS HE GETS REP
THAT IABO PERSUADE HIM O
ALNG
ARI HEAREST EARLR TODAY TA THECN
THEY HAVE HIM ON TAPE,
EXT, VT CTURES. GOTICTHE
THE D THBOXES.
NEYS WEREN'T  DOCUMINUBSTANTIAL
JEOPARDY, AND I THINK WILL B
E TESTIFIES.
D HEDO THE
M, A LESS
NOW THY ONCE DID.
AND,IS S WHICH WERE UNFORTUNATHE
T
>> NOT EVEN GIVE H T CHANCE.
>>UT
ANOTHER OFFER.
DAS E
GOING TO GO ON THE BACK BURNER .
HE ILULV
SEJANUAR IORGIA.ERE'S ALSO THE O
INDICTMES N THE  POSBL
SINGLE MT ING ANTH T THE JUDGES
SENSE O
EITHER HOLOF
HOLD OFF OS UNTIL THIS IS
>> I AGREER
ME W
SS.MOON.
E I BELIEVE, AS WOULD BE TYPICAE
IS SOME COORDINATION ON
ABOUT T THIS R ABOUT TIMES
D U  HIME AL I DE
THE ILLE
EXPTION OF JANUARY, WHICH
WION PROCEED
N'